hello and welcome to this video this is
a 25-10 game playing bad days from the
US so I'm trying to get above 2000 year
but it's tricky lost the game before
that when my opponent played
exceptionally well so I nims oh yeah am
I going to play them samish again hmm
let's play three and see what happens
III and are you three years what I
normally do yeah nowadays people really
mostly castle they all see what them
what the top players play and adopt that
I can let's see maybe I'm going to play
against my own repertoire here with c5
now black now goes usually see 5 or d5
this is a common myth that in the NIMS
oh you can show your center with pieces
that's usually not happening Black is
just them delaying his pawns occupying
the center right here you really yeah I
think you have to play see 5 45 yeah c5
so Knight f3 now might lead to the
huebner variation what I'm recommending
in my my book hmm I can also go nighty
too maybe this line is some not well on
not well that sentence not going to end
well it's not not much in fashion at the
moment why does making sure that he can
always recapture on c3 with the night
quite often black now go go d 5
by far the most most common move and
then we will get an IQ p position
isolated Queens pawn when I looked at
this line for my book I tried to figure
out if there's something else that you
can play something that is not leading
to the iqp but I really couldn't find
anything decent so I think this is what
what black should go for here the move
Queen d5 is surprisingly interesting
it's something that I studied a little
bit in my book but this is the main line
and here knight c6 is the most common
move even though rupee age is also
interesting the idea is to drop the
bishop back to evade and then
potentially go g6 and Bishop g7 at a
later stage it looks a bit slow but it
is definitely a playable move 96 0 Evers
them yeah it's the the normal the normal
way to go mmm so a couple of options
Bishop c2 is the most popular move and
I'm trying this angling for 23 there's
also a bishop efore for example or moves
like a three now it's it's a very
flexible position where many ideas are
possible so let's see what is going to
go into play I like the movie pata again
trying to put the bishop all the way
back
but it's not something that them is
forced or anything black and try a
couple of things this also move like
night back to have six covering age
seven yeah I probably go rookie idea
black will normally play with g6 in case
/ 23 move special onesie to answer is
some as blunted why g6 so how are we
going to play this black wall drop back
to evade threatening night to before so
probably hmm it's an interesting
question i would like to go with
something like Queen g3 and maybe trying
to play h 4 and so on but not sure about
it may be lending some support to the D
porn is helpful also in case of black
moving this night from d5 the rukon d1
supports the central breakthrough I'm
not sure about my bishop ones c2 now
that I have provoked this this g6 move
through me not that clear that the
bishop is that great down for example
you could argue that it is better placed
on b3 was something like between f3
Bishop before might also come to mind
yeah he probably has my book there and
it's looking at the lines
again so I'm going a 3m preventing night
two before i move that i have have to
play almost in any case so Bishop g7
yeah something that looked interesting
to me as soon as queen g3 em try to play
h4 h5 I wonder if that is an idea it
definitely is i'm just not sure if it is
if it is any good okay let's try that
also maybe Bishop g5 at the right moment
yeah I'm really convinced that blacks
position is ok here but what can you do
have to try some kind of line with wine
and see what happened and sees he kissed
completely he's playing this exactly
like black should play this it's kind of
the best possible setup and also I think
a good move order that you chose their
knight c6 Luke a g6 looks very very
refined let's see this is the new
account why is five-minute writing is
really bad but 15-minute is it's quite
ok yeah some people simply are hopeless
at blitz speeds and need a little bit
more time to think this kind of account
with like 11 12 hundred and five minute
and 1800 in them in 15 minute this is
something that you see more often than
you might think for example among my
students there are number of people who
really am are not able to play any
decent blitz games let alone Bullet
games but they can play pretty
well in 15 minute or like here even
longer time controls like him 25 10 or
30 minute per game awesome so this is
indeed possible some people are just not
can not made for the quick moves and
sometimes those some blitz games are
simply decided on Mouse speed and then
good nerves and quite often people get
good positions but they lack those
skills and then spoil them the efforts
all the invested time and good moveset
down the drain okay so let's see what
black does heum a common idea for black
is to play something like a knight takes
c3 btx III and then e 5 breaking up the
center and opening up the c8 bishop even
though here it would be a bit
frustrating and that is possible because
I just played the rook to d1 capital of
moves ago which should make it more
difficult to play five ready
another idea that often is some is plate
is an IT sound knight c6 to e7 and
possibly to f5 it's also something that
makes quite some sense uh-huh I swear
it's not hearing me okay
hmm
well night f5 if I take it he takes f 95
mmm the deep one is passed
I'm not quite sure if night f5 is really
a move to fear on or not net f4 also
looks interesting ye can takes you three
probably it doesn't doesn't lead to
anything special
g5 and there's a couple of interesting
moves that that can be tried currently
I'm really not in a position to push my
deep on anytime soon would be a good
idea or each for that was my original
intention but after each 1i defy that
will definitely have to check on f5 and
I'm not sure that this is any good but
should have 5ef 9525 hmm i don't really
believe much in this position for me
well maybe the deep pond is indeed quite
good 93 possibly d5 Bishop f4 after H
495 Bishop f5 you have 95 this also
roped xe2 very weird move but it is some
may be possible night c7 however our 97
rupee aid now that looks wrong it looks
wrong for black going into the sisters
discovery Bishop f4 and so on okay come
on let's go edge fun oh it's a bit
difficult to play basically against your
own openings and in this case it really
is okay dokay open opening with the book
behaving yeah when I studied this for
the book it really here it took it took
a long time to look at everything hmm so
he can of course just play something
like be six or so and just wait
proceedings with with h5
we're five looks very principle though
hmm yeah neither five or six those moves
look look logically maybe night xe3 but
somehow that doesn't fit well with 97
played on the move before b6f let's also
also possibility try to complete
development but I know that looks look
slow night f5 is the most principal
that one okay so probably he wants to
put it on c6 and does not want to go b6
okay that's the case of having set a you
should probably say be some h5 one
reason why h5 or HOH five and then
taking on g6 is interesting is that
after the age pawns have been traded and
move like Bishop g5 cannot easily be
answered by f6 because then g6 would be
very weak that's a big difference to the
position with the age pawns still being
in existence here after Bishop g5 it's
tricky for black to get out of out of
that pin okay can click move the queen
of course but you don't get rid of that
Bishop easily so is it Bishop c6 now
Jeff looks very very logical here night
f5 is not even on taking ed that's the
night hanging now maybe maybe you can do
it it was also hanging but that is a
very weird idea so I don't really expect
95 to happen an interesting point might
be that I can also go h6 in some cases a
pawn going all the way up on the
sixth-ranked can be very annoying
setting up all kinds of back rank issues
and yeah issues relating to the fact
that blacks king is very limited by a
pawn on age 6 even though normally I
would just same take it and be happy
that we have weakened the King position
a little bit after move like h6 and
Bishop h eight or so it's not quite
clear how wide yeah continues yeah yet
but it plays it anyway so antique here
right this step well let's think about
it it should f5 GTX as age six and black
resigns so is he really going to play
Bishop f5 EF and play on that that we
are tactic 95 fruitcake c2 it's really
weird I have Bishop g5 by the way that's
an interesting interesting fact
ok I'm going to take why is he playing
92 then that sets interesting that's
interesting hmm yeah yeah that's really
a possibility
yeah night takes c3 this is this is
definitely going to be played now
they're not definitely a strong but it's
what I expect if he takes with the e
porn 95 rookie to Bishop g5 okay so he's
not threatening night take C 2 so well
okay Bishop d3 but the rook is also
hanging so I have to take it's actually
hmm not completely clear how i should
take pawn takes is possible pawn takes
it takes at five but i don't really see
a great continuation then the good thing
that i'm going to play the CN that let's
not waste time the good thing about this
move is that now Bishop g5 is really a
bit annoying mmm i think i'm just going
to play it Bishop f6 there is taking and
95 which feels really wrong for black
with 97 being on the cards what do you
see going to play now f6 looks damn ugly
hmm and there's 95 ideas like a queen
bee 695
yeah is f6 going to be played f6 i don't
think i have a tactic like h takes 26 I
probably just have to move the bishop
well and after a bishop move the g6 porn
seems so like an issue yeah maybe still
f6 Bishop f4 g5 this kind of thing
probably has to do something like that
hmm I don't see anything great I'm f6
Bishop f4 g5 hmm it might be might be
playable I mean at least from a
technical point of view Bishop c7 my
even aphorism anyway I didn't have much
choice so I don't need to second-guess
myself here
yeah after f6 do I really have some
choice where'd you go Bishop e3 Bishop
e3 and then religi fire home no it looks
it looks bad but maybe it just happens
don't really see anything super grade
after f6
let's say there should be three g5 many
threatening f4
age six hmm seems also weird huh I'm not
quite sure where I'm going after have
six I don't really like the idea of
going to d jus f6 Bishop e3 g5f for is
that something it looks wrong somehow
but it doesn't really help how things
look like they have to be good and
that's the only thing that counts it's
really something that computers have
have told us that the appearance of move
sometimes doesn't really matter much
sometimes really weird-looking moves can
be strong if there's and concretes
justification for it the anti-wind f6
mmmm I don't really know where to go
Bishop e3 g5 it's really not that great
but should f/4g 5 Bishop c7 even f4 is a
move Bishop to 8ft x 23 and blackest
probably probably better hmm
okay I think trollee to d2l I don't
really see any point of going to e3 and
stumbling into d5 ng5 I'm sorry hmm very
weird so what now I was thinking t5
maybe yeah let's do this and I'm not
let's not waste lots of time this is my
only a substantial asset the other d
porn even though blacks um King position
is definitely not great down with this
f6 g5 business but I'm not in a position
to get a quick attack going so cannot
expect some song yeah some big kingside
attack anytime soon how do i get my
pieces improve them night and Bishop are
not doing that much
and itís somewhat okay then the bishop
on d 2 is just not right okay he's going
F form now Bishop g4 is probably one IDM
something like Quincy eight threatening
Bishop g4 anyway I have to go to a three
that's not Matt album not much else I
guess something like queen bee three
there was Bishop g4 immediately
we can even go f5 here activating the g7
bishop
how do I get night and Bishop activated
those pieces are really bad can I
somehow get the night let's say to
defund Bishop to c3 something like 92 m
but it runs into g4 things 92 Bishop see
394 this kind of thing yeah I expected
this
Kim
ship ship poison is in a very annoying
idea hmm i wonder if age six is
something to consider age six possibly
94 but he always has the direct Bishop
g4
hmm
it's very difficult to keep that poem or
they exchange for that matter with
Bishop g4
hmm
ok I think I'm going to succeed I don't
know every I'm have to make a move at
some point I mean to perfectly honest
this guy is rated 11 hundred and five
minute which means like a little bit
more than knowing the rules of chess so
if he's just out place me at a 25-minute
came all the power to him but there
should be some kind of bad move coming
once in a while so let's see what
happens Bishop g4 Queen d3 bishop d 1
i've got d7 that was some an idea of
this and possibly 925
Bishop g4 1925 queen is 6 d-7 is not so
convincing you can even go up to eight
so Bishop g4 i will go Queen d3 being
ready 47 and 95 as mentioned so going
here
so what is he going to do group the aid
58 hmm I know just to be one then on 95
is also looking quite powerful go into
d7
is that some kind of age six related IDM
or should I just play like would be one
and get rid of the check on man got the
one okay i mean i do might remind him
that much to take the rook but hmm like
to go 95 but 26 is just going to happen
turkey
it doesn't seem so convincing here I
mean something like h6 you really
probably just takes and it doesn't feel
like I've got anything great down and
maybe 94 then some light before could be
interesting 94 immediately probably just
bishop age five
hmm
h6 Bishop takes Knight e form then
bishops III mmmm
and also it's not really convincing you
can play all kinds of moves just back to
g7 probably 9 to 5 any can take you one
that's another little issue but not
quite sure if this is this is really the
issue
thank you for you can play all kinds of
moves that's really difficult to
evaluate as mentioned 95 this Queen d6
simply and nothing great happens at
least I don't see it
maybe h6 Bishop takes 95 and then Bishop
c3 and okay I have to play with at some
point here difficult very difficult to
play this this is some very calculation
heavy
so it's going to take that I guess then
95 was my idea but the tempo and then
Bishop c3 activating those pieces shifty
1h takes g7 should be should be good
compensation maybe this is not the case
I mean it should be 1h takes g6 Bishop
back to h5 awesome would be very
cold-blooded album but but possible I
was thinking Bishop age 695 Queen d6
bishops III threatening night takes f6
or is he playing just rub the aid or
something like that on this hmm
yeah three sharp position
it takes the one I mean I can try to
just recapture should be one look to one
Bishop age six hmm yeah maybe 95
violated that doesn't look so convincing
Bishop the 1h takes g7 is probably
better now that's probably the better
choice but I expect him to play Bishop
age 6 really
I'm going to stop the video just briefly
ok I'm back it took on age six just had
to drink something and I didn't want to
have my gulps there on video I had
something really as spicy for dinner and
I needed some water will badly so 95
Bishop g7 and now I thought bishops III
actually but well you can take on d 197
is also possible just trying to try to
get an exchange back so that only the
age porn got lost in the process maybe
maybe that's not such a bad idea Nancy
seven Bishop t1 t1 and still have the
deep on and his some King position is
not exactly ideal bishops III Bishop t1
look T one who made rupee six months
that going to be enough okay i have
ninety-seven hmm
doesn't feel like it should be enough
okay let's do this trading my business
in that way so I just go look the one
here you cannot escape this anyway this
Fork so I'm really a pawn down the edge
porn got lost but the deep one is
dangerous maybe I should have played
Quincy five huh I know he has got Queen
f7 okay
hmm
yeah okay it's going to return the
exchange that's no way around that I
guess question is how 3g for that a move
now I can don't think so ok so here is
there any point in 25 or Quincy for
stuff like that you know it isn't done
so I'm going to take before you before
he secures this and now what is it going
to do rook is six maybe or something
okay bishops III looks like the normal
move here
or anything else that I think bishops
III just it just looks very very natural
to do that bishop is bad on the two I
want to support the deep one I don't
think that Bishop a 50 Bishop before can
be can be better yeah okay Queen d5
would be a good move if it would be my
movie m25 queen of 77 that looks very
strong
I wonder move like Brooke is six maybe I
can go quinta f5 no rookie one check
oops that's not going to work so Queen
d5 maybe the idea 25mm the idea is to
threaten to queen is six queen is 6 d-7
if I go queen d 5 is he going to go push
ff8 then Bishop takes f6 yeah that must
be good for word
king of aid but now I can take right
take and d7 i will see stopping me from
promoting i guess he hasn't txt XD 7 and
touchdown write no checks yeah
very tough game I think I really don't
think I wasn't good shape them didn't I
know I didn't feel right this is this
gphi their form happening to me and I
know I didn't like the position can
almost pre-move that can you flip
probably if the if the aid queen is a
legal move you can probably play it
black resigns there was a tough game so
let's go back a little bit here um it's
a fairly normal opening position as
mentioned okay I tried this this thing
trying to go for h4 h5 i played this
certainly normal I went age form and he
went Bishop d7 yeah i was expecting this
move and i wasn't sure at all but i
thought that this might be might be
interesting for me something like this
and then try to play for them for the
deep on and move that i didn't really
take into account is this one now given
by stockfish age five
the engine gives equal but this is a
position that well it might be equal but
it's also very unbalanced let's say with
the deep on black bags got the bishop
pair it's a very very unclear situation
I don't think that black can be in
really bad shape here position feels
very solid fam you played Bishop d7 I
went age five and now we went night f5
and cakes cheeks that has to be played
and he takes what's interesting very
good idea but it might be might be on 95
rupee to this is not trapping anything I
was thinking maybe Bishop g5 ism when
this position but okay it didn't happen
but this was what i was thinking during
the game very unclear position this
happened you know it takes eat eggs yeah
this of course it's not possible so here
and I went Bishop g5 yeah and with
hindsight I'm not quite sure about this
I really didn't look so much that I have
six I was mostly thinking about this
move and after that I'm much much better
with Nazi seven coming i wasn't sure if
i win the exchange but the computer
basically confirms that so we had to
play up six anyway but I really
underestimated this going back and he
went g5 and this is not clear at all I
mean this looks strange somehow this is
Pau information but what am I going to
do about it
the computer is on 000 on something
around this it wants to go queen f.3d 5
is that possibly really a mistake and
take now the engine gives some moves
like age six and then f5 or f5
immediately yeah I think f5 was the move
that are also mentioned but ultimately
didn't happen also Bishop f5 isn't is a
good move with maybe Queen d7 coming
yeah I think black is okay the deep on I
mean okay more than okay I black is
better the deep one is not really going
anywhere and he can use the bishops
nicely if he gets in at five somehow i
also like Bishop f5 him with this this
kind of idea sunny that the engine gives
g4 here that to move that I probably
would not have considered looks
especially weird if black just goes back
and threatens this I think this is a
rubbish move and I black its fornia but
I suspect that this also shouldn't be
bad no at least not immediately yeah
rupee one is given by the engine and the
sex is not the top choice yeah rupee one
of course was there yeah what's what
yeah maybe you can say conservative move
but Jim I felt that pushing the pawn
should be a should be interesting to try
if he goes here now check and take so
Bishop g4 is not possible i don't i
don't think i even saw that during the
game I just felt that rookie one is kind
of slow and I wanted to push it should
reform may be normal looking
engine gives bishops is six that that I
didn't really think about yeah but
certainly not bad Bishop sizzix okay
this happened and I played queen bee
three and now of course it cannot take
on the one and this looks very logical
in a way also one of the computers top
choices and now the engine wants to play
night if I here I really was unsure
ultimately settling for age six trying
to dislodge this Bishop there from g7
engine wants to go ahead with this
probably also introducing this kind of
possibility in some cases it's a
different way of dropping the H porn
where we had clear this is even possible
check funny funny way to draw on okay
age six and black took this which looks
very normal but should be one near this
is are suspected to be more critical and
now interesting i think i would have
taken on g7 the engine gives look to you
one is this bad then takes bishop age
595 this was this was something that i
was thinking about I Scott rookies six
here hmm now that's true or this move
may be Queen e6 yeah maybe it really is
better than to take here I wasn't sure i
think i would have taken on g7 but
this might be might be stronger the
engine is giving an equal funny enough
with the very height it even gave King
h8 very intuitive move up okay takes
takes takes and now black can return
stuff check check high-quality
surprisingly stop which is always around
0 0.2 0.3 for for one side Bishop age
six and now 95 yeah and now the engine
gives me a pretty substantial advantage
maybe add the right hands down Bishop g7
927 mmhmm yeah exactly the game and I
had the feeling that this should be good
with my D porn but but I wasn't it
wasn't totally sure digs and digs I look
see one no that's a move I did not see
you will see one wins for Luke c7 really
is that strong that's remarkable why is
it that strong so I went here Luke see
one so let's say rookie 6 I am Bishop
before and this is just I'm just doing
it without any tactics just cover that
and then Luke c7 yeah that's very strong
hmm now hook see what wasn't on my
agenda at all the engine ultimately
gives stuff like that yeah this is great
for white
got this pawn king go d 7 on the right
circumstance b6 this week hmm so this is
a bad move it gives away most of my
advantage although the engine still
gives me like one pawn and after Queen
d5 I'm mooning right mmm yeah I'm
winning king of 7s tougher though this
is what I expected and then be sure
before as good keeping this and now
looky one gathered that ultimately wins
winsome a piece black is so tied down
here just doesn't have anything better
than but should be six if we play some
something like this can I can go here
and win pretty easily so this is some
happening and why does a piece up still
need a little bit of technical player
but it should win it should win I guess
some cases two points for peace is not
that clear but this should be a win so
he went down and after Queenie six this
is a touchdown for the for the deep horn
yeah a tough battle I really am put up a
good good resistance they're very very
good game here bye bye bad days
ultimately he ran into this guy when he
committed this this mistake also when
the time was ticking down and this is
maybe reason why is not higher rated in
five minutes yes some people really have
this problem so the cloth gets down
really really low that they tend to make
them yeah big mistakes blunders and this
is why they are better in 15 or 30
minutes chest then in
chess yeah I hope you enjoyed this video
thanks for watching